COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MARCH
EIGHTH IS HEREBY CALL TO ORDER.
COPIES WE ADVICE ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING IS BEING MADE
TODAY'S PRAYER PROCEEDING. AND
IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED. LA MER
SECTOR BASED CULTURAL COOLEY.
HERE CUNNINGHAM. ALLEN BROUGH.
CARILLO.
BONTA
FRIEDMAN GRAYSON THERE. THIS
AREA SOLACE.
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND WE HAVE THE CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
NUMBERS CUNNINGHAM SECOND OF OUR
MOST RECENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM FACT CUNNINGHAM AYE
ALLEN BROUGH CARILLO. CARILLO
AYE CERVANTES FRIEDMAN.
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE KNOWS AREA
SOLACE SOLACE AYE WALDRON.
I.
VERY GOOD.
THE MOTIONS PASSED AND.
ONLY ONE AND.
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA.
YES I HAVE SIRVENTES I AM
PLEASED THAT WORLD PRO.
AND THOSE RULES FOR HIS RETURN.
FOR THE SAKE OF